Jennifer is in Reno
how are you Jennifer I'm great how are
you thank you so much you're such a doll
I really appreciate it what's your heart
how can I help
Dave we have a elderly mother she's
about 86 a little bit of dementia
kicking in and my sister and I wanted to
get her to her doctor to get her to see
if she could be declared incompetent
because she can't handle her money and
finances and all she's refinanced her
house five times bought the house in
like 1952 for about 50,000 now owes
248,000 on it
once we stated to her crazy sister Kelly
about this she took our mother to
another attorney and redid her trust and
everything and she became her medical
directive and basically took our mom
away from us she moved into her home and
we've been figuring out after hearing
rethinking of stories that are talks
that we've had with our mom that our
sisters pretty much been brainwashing
her slowly over a period of time and all
we can have now is a phone relationship
with our mother and I didn't know we did
get an attorney before our when our
sister we found out she took her to
another attorney we hired an attorney
and he said you know girls your you've
already spent a thousand dollars within
just a few weeks he said if you want to
really put in some money into this we
can continue on and we decided not to
and I didn't know if you have any other
suggestions on what we can do if there's
a group or somebody that could help us
out or do we just need to just walk away
well I think you're left with one of two
options and that's what your attorney
proposed to you is that you know you're
going to spend a lot of money on doing
this is there a lot of money involved in
her estate
um she has a want to say about $250,000
in an investment account and then her
house if she were to sell it it would be
worth at least 1.3 million simply
because of the location so unless your
sister has milked that drive since
you've been pushed out of the picture
there's some money there yes
she's possible she's burned off some of
that but or it possible all of it if
she's in control of a power of attorney
I and I guess the process would probably
be to shoot to challenge the documents
that gave your sister the power were
signed by a person who wasn't legally
able to sign them because of her medical
condition you to bring the doctor
forward to prove that right right and
you're just gonna have to go through
that process if you want to fight it but
the problem is it breaks your heart I
mean it's your mom and even if she's
crazy she's your sister and there's this
you know just angst that just goes that
your heart just breaks but you're either
you know realistically you either just
can walk away from it and just go I'm
not going to fight it I'm not going to
spend the emotional energy or the money
to go after this situation and to shut
my sister down or I'm going to be all-in
but you cannot be sort of in on
something like this exactly and I just
I've got to go all the way and there's
not someone there's not a there's not
this mysterious group out there this
swoops in and takes care of
dysfunctional 65 year olds you know
there's just not because your sister is
the one that's that's in control of
everything is not listening to anyone
correct and so I mean there's no
negotiating or reasoning anymore that's
all out the window I assume yes it is
our our mother told both Perry and I
you're never to come to my house again
and the sad part is as my niece had a
baby just recently and she used to be
very close with our mother and I think
my mom has seen the baby maybe once he's
only a couple months old
and she drives over to the house our
crazy sister Kelly comes out with our
mom gets her into my niece's car and
then she goes and like drives her
through in-and-out burger which she
loves and you know has her for a few
hours yeah I just I just like to get the
word out to people maybe we'll try to
start something just to make people more
aware well there's not really anything I
mean that there's a legal system and
that's all there is there's not a
there's nothing you could have done to
have stopped this short of physically
threatening your crazy sister right yeah
but you know but but that's the only
thing you can do is is the legal system
and that is to go in and have her
physically removed from the situation by
the Sheriff's Department have your
mother institutionalized based on the
fact that and all the power the legal
power taken away from your sister
because it was given to her under your
under the way you're telling the story
he was given to her by a lady who didn't
have the the mental capabilities to sign
that document yes and so that could be
undone I would suspect if everything can
be proven out as you see it and so
that's what you've got to get into and I
don't know I mean is it worth it to
fight it through emotionally or
financially I mean you probably could
make you probably could break even and
if you spend a hundred thousand dollars
on this you probably get it back out of
your share of the estate right and I
think just our biggest thing is we just
wanted to help care for our mother you
know comes down to it yeah and you know
there's only one way to do that and
that's forcibly yeah that I'm aware of
um you know and so I think you just got
this out are we going to stand back and
pray and just watch this and hope that
something happens usually doesn't in
these situations or are we going to take
action and you know legally just
completely overwhelm them and you know
get for your mother's own good get her
out from under the control of this
person and decide that and you know just
got aside if you're willing to do that
or not and is it worth it
and is your mother of the right mind
enough that you'd be going against her
wishes when you did that and you know
you only you know that kind of stuff I
don't and she stated her wishes but are
they based in her dementia or are they
based in something else I mean I don't
know I don't have any idea what's going
on here so but you guys just have to
decide how hard how much hardball do you
want to play but I really for your sake
I would say make a complete decision and
then stay at peace with that decision
and the decision is we're going to do
nothing and this is really heartbreaking
and sad but I'm at peace with doing
nothing or we're going to do this but
you're keep you know this thing of the
Lone Ranger is going to write in and
you're going to hear the cavalry
trumpets sound and here comes the
Calvary to save you there's not one
there's not one you're it and so you
either surrender this and just be at
peace with that or you take up arms and
you fight your way through it and you're
at peace with that and that that's the
only advice I can give you but what's
killing you it sounds like to me is that
you you know you still want to fight but
you don't but I do but I don't and I
think that having one foot on the over
the fence is what's driving you nuts
and part of that just comes from the
fact that you love your mother and your
hearts broken over this understand that
understand I'm sorry you're facing this
lot of families face this by the way a
lot of families face this so this is one
of the reasons we recommend folks and
I'm not sure that this suggestion would
have solved that particular situation
but we highly suggest to you that you
get your wills done and that you keep
them done I don't care if you're 20 or
yours 80 you need a will and you need to
cover your will with everyone that's
involved sisters brothers everybody have
a reading of the will out loud where
everybody knows what's going on and
everybody knows what's expected and then
your wishes are very clearly known to
everyone and then if you have an issue
with the men
something everybody knows what's
supposed to happen hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]